I must say that when this but I saw snow
white my mind opened and it has never
shot sins because he just looked the
whole idea of a separate world which
wasn't as boring as North Toronto okay -
get me out of here where's the exit and
anyway and I found the exit actually it
was really into this stuff anyway out
came Fantasia Andy and pushing the
directions Oh different directions all
at once
and I'm just going to run a very short
clip of Bill titleist animation of the
sort of demigod or whatever it is in the
mountain on the night of Bald Mountain
and he's into an area I've labeled it
super realism where they we use
live-action maybe as a guide bit but you
take it somewhere else I was scared as
hell when I saw this but it's a it's
it's a big step towards a different
thing and then the year the next year
out came Dumbo 1941 and Dumbo I think is
the I've chosen Dumbo for imagination
and we're gonna run the pinger at pink
elephants sequence and see fantastic
entertainment and I was I was working
with with Sidney Lumet's the great film
director for all the crime dramas in New
York and I was working on the titles not
the titles but a sequence pre-title live
action sequence with Sidney and and
nobody knows I ever did it but we did it
together and I was talking about Dumbo
one day and he said Dumbo a major major
work and I said oh great he said
yeah the perfect film its each sequence
is totally self-contained totally
complete and still pushes the picture
forward the perfect model of the film I
think